这是我用AI做的运动品牌广告, 全程没有视牌, 不需要模特, 我是如何做到的呢, 先看成天
I live two lives
One slow, quiet
The dinosaur is here, kids run fast
Wrapped in family warmth and gentle mornings
Stop it, both of you please
The other raw, unchained, where I chase my fire on the court
I balance calm with strength for the life we share together
I just wear the comfort that fits every part of me
这次用到的制作软件是Lib TV
老样子我仍然建议大家采用无线画布模式进行制作
点击添加图片节点这里内置了多款模型
目前市面上先进的图片模型基本上都内置了
大家可以根据自己的需求去选择
比如这里跑步的镜头我就用了Lib的Nano Pro
这个产品是一个针对美国市场的运动故事
所以其实一开始我并没有先生成人物
而是先确定产品的这个感觉
于是我做了这张图
当有了这张图以后
我尝试去做了人物的信息
我把在跑步机的这个中景产品图片
喂给了AI
然后AI就自己脑补了这个角色长相出来
当我们确认要用这个角色以后
我们就可以把这个角色创建一个白底图
我们可以创建它的三四角图
后面在控制角色一致性的时候
方便我们进行直接的链接
当我们所有的图片都生成完毕以后
第二步就是视频生成
当图片生成完以后
我们可以不用推出软件
就在本身画部中点击这个图片的加号
在立部中创建图片的这个视频节点
这里也可以根据我们的画面
去选择相应的视频模型生成
可以看到模型是非常全的
C-Dance, CleanView, 这些主流模型基本都有
我们可以根据我们想要的这个画面比例
进行这个比例的设置
你也可以输入你的提示词
让你的角色动起来
一般视频生成完成以后
我都会直接用AI去做音乐
因为这样的话可以避免版权问题
因为我大多现在做的广告
都是一些商业广告
如果去找现成的音乐的话
对我来讲非常麻烦
所以音乐我也直接是用Leap里面
自带的音频去生成的
我们可以直接在这个画部节点
去点击右键创建这个节点里面的音频
这里我生成音乐的模型是11 Music V3
之前我很多人问我这个音乐是怎么做的
我现在直接把模型告诉大家
当然你可以选择其他模型
音乐生成方面
我会大概描述一下我想要的感觉
比如这个音动广告
我就直接把我主角的人设
和我想要的这个风格
包括这个音乐的这个节奏
直接输进去
这个提示是送给大家
当然音乐也不太可能一次性抽准
我是抽了可能有七次左右
最后在两条里面选了
一条能够用的去合成
这个就需要大家去调试
最后我们把声称的视频和音乐放在一起进行剪辑
这样一个商业级别的广告实战就完成了
现在的一些工具
其实已经能够节约非常多的时间
帮助我们快速创作和设计
希望我的实战案例分享对你有帮助
赶紧用起来吧
做出属于你自己的商业广告片
我是罐头
点赞高的话
我持续分享干货
咱们下期节目再见